okay so this is Marceline's closet bears
the snail so Eli is the snail on this
episode I never looked for the snail
only it I sir forget it's in there Oh
but speaking of in there with the
titling Marceline's closet and given the
last episode we saw her and I was sort
of almost wonder if they were gonna tap
I'm a little bit more good but no it's
it's an episode I thought we were going
even more about her too and it was just
sort of you know it's cute and you find
out a touch more at least on the surface
yeah but this is something that I was
kind of wondering like because I we
didn't bring us up in the V log last
time but I was saying the point where
the Ice King was singing Marceline song
it's like wait did they ever meet I
don't remember the meeting and then in
this one when she's looking at her diary
on there it says like Gunter like that's
the name of her band or something so now
I'm wondering if like they did have some
sort of history or something like that I
said every thought it was like a name of
a band I just thought it was going to
her because I don't know why not Gunter
it's so much like you look like you
spell sorry the same way Metallica is
bills are like a big g8 that was her
band Gunter
oh the band name needs alternates
actually in how thing about cuz did she
have that whole thing where she was like
a kid and that was cowlick after the
apocalypse and stuff like that and we
kind of know the ice king it looks like
kind of caused it in a way or as
something directly do so yeah but now
it's like yeah what is the connection
now I'm really fascinated oh okay let's
get to this episode so they're Finn and
Jake are supposed to come over they're
supposed to not go inside the house were
supposed to wait for her to come home
cuz run gym with the balloon yeah
they're gonna jam with the blue which is
pretty funny um Jory not you really
don't like that sound do you know
and she really screams when that bird
came in and made the alarm sound yeah I
can see why I can actually understand
that
oh but yeah and so they they go in and
she comes in of course they hide in the
closet and she's seeing personal stuff
about herself from her diary and Finn
and Jake feel awful man why God let's
get out of here where we're crossing the
line and stuff and it's just about them
trying to get away and at the very end
she finally finds out and they tell the
truth and she says oh that's okay I've
hidden in your house all the time which
is a great punchline and then I like how
at the end they're there and they're
just constantly looking around like
Mercedes and I love Jake showering with
the towel he walks around naked anyway
it's no no yes underwear does he you
learn that with Donnie she done he tells
Donnie he needs to wear pants and he
goes you need to wear pants let me go
side too and he pulls out the little
silken uh Betsy wears I'm proud about
that okay so well there you go that
makes still doesn't make too much sense
to wear a towel in the shower but still
it's pretty baby gets out it puts
another towel on yeah so that wasn't
really funny um yeah I think
see now I'm just looking for stuff like
what was hid the rest of the note
because she was like you know Jake just
sir you know I'll be back soon Blee blah
blah blah bloop don't go inside and I
was like well sing the rest of the note
that means something I don't know um but
no it was a it was a funny episode I
actually really did think we were gonna
learn a lot more you know there's gonna
be a lot more like you exposed about
well okay she is exposed at this one I
mean she Finn sees are naked and we hear
her go to the bathroom that's a little
weird
the the peeing was the one that threw me
off the most because she goes into the
bathroom and you know you're just
waiting for the flush but you actually
your zip yeah yeah and then it's like we
just heard there actually pee yeah like
that that was a little weird you don't
you
even even TV shows rarely go that far
yeah and it's it was a lot like like say
you guys see it in movies and stuff but
it's like even if it wasn't like a kids
movie or something you just can't be
like it's a little weird yeah III think
it's just us like we just don't see it
that's why Wonka or here or whatever
that's why we're uncomfortable by me
it's like people talk about II hear
jokes felt I know you're gonna make me
pee haha no I think it's it's a tortoise
I wouldn't say I'm embarrassed by it or
anything or weirded out but it's just
it's not something that's common yeah we
just never hear it so it's it's not
something that's shown in TV or cartoons
like he'll think back before when
someone's like I'm going to the bathroom
oh my god Derek she they said the b-word
yeah you know and I don't know about how
he saw her naked yeah I don't know
because he was I'm not going back out
there you know as an adult it's not a
bad joke okay because it's kind of like
what did he see I because it's like you
assume she's no longer there but it's
like you see she has a bat nose for the
first time which was kind of cool
seeing that she has a bat nose yeah um
and I don't leer especially a pointy
ears either I think no you the first if
I remember if I remember you saw that
before okay but the bat nose of the
prison so maybe something looks
different under there we don't know but
they'll both look at that is something I
can't think about kids I'm so like you
know what that just feels weird like you
guys seeing naked girls like I don't go
out there no it's too scary
III can't do it it's I don't know that's
a little weird you know what I mean like
this one has a wig it's weird his
reactionaries reaction his reaction to
it no I think his reaction was more
because when she's starting to sing from
the diary and you have genuine arguing
y'all been going too far we crossed the
line it's probably a modest thing yeah
and then it gets to that point where he
goes out there and he said he's like oh
my god I've gone even further than I
thought was even possible I think yeah I
think it was you know that's probably
true yeah and I do really like that
there in the closet which you started to
sing the personal stuff he's like don't
work they're both panicking like we're
going too far we should not be going
this far
I like that I like there's a lot more
people like you no no I like something
else you have to think of how many of
your friends have you actually seen
naked that's my thing if you see a
random person nude it's no big deal in a
sense like oh that's kind of weird
seeing so new but just imagine walking
in on one of your friends female yeah
completely naked and they don't notice
you so you just kind of walk in you see
them completely naked
think about how uncomfortable you long
and would you ever tell them well again
that's kind of why that's kind of it
maybe it just feels a little weird to
kiss I guess no I agree so I'm just I'm
just saying I think the way that Finn
reacted makes perfect sense I guess so
um walking about so nude is one thing
walking and I'm like what are your best
friends I guess because like okay even
as adults we don't always know how to
feel so as a kid yeah you know someone
sees somebody naked just be real like oh
oh like that it's like I'm probably
reading too much into it honest I think
you are you know but still weird I don't
know but trying to think what else I
mean it was funny I like when they were
trying to speak out I love it when I
love that coming across the spider that
was yeah I love the paper plane saying
all the things I do it does most of them
and then goes to the trash I mean that's
hugely funny um and I love it when the
spider bites Jake and he doesn't scream
there's definitely some funny stuff in
it um I guess I don't know from the
title I was expecting like wow another
happy one but I guess after the last one
to whom hey we didn't need to very heavy
one oh but it title makes sense they're
in Marceline's closet no I don't I mean
usually these setups invite a lot more
but you know maybe that's part of it too
maybe maybe it's kind of like were the
people watching the closet two of the
shows deal okay Mike your own business
focus on Finn and Jake come on there
they don't care what you think about
focus I don't listen to her Marceline
that that's rude
you know well that's that's something of
the Creator in Stimpy used to say say
you got a lot of questions and people
saying our brains to be gaiety tell ya I
don't know that's none of my business
yeah that's a great answer the same
thing has come up for like so many
characters now like SpongeBob and
Patrick it's like are you people really
looking that deeply at cartoon
characters like that day you would know
they're actually gay and they I think
part of it now is like because you know
I mean it's just with you know gay
people's them achieve so much now sort
of like you know well if they are gay
hey that's okay you know like when they
go it's like hey what you don't burn or
anywhere gave the whole time you know
it's like oh dear emotions and thoughts
do you know just come on same people I
hate the coca-cola America the Beautiful
what no idea what any of this stuff is
okay
there's thankfully a smaller but a
population of idiots in the world and
that's you probably knew that but that's
a specific factor of that you should
probably know about not that there's
thankfully not there's really as many as
there used to be but they're still kind
of there and they're fun to laugh at and
when you have to bring it it's just
funny because obviously they don't
understand things very well so when you
can point to a cartoon and say that's
gay and that was something that was good
it helps them ish hopefully proudly nod
but you'll know what they can't learn
from a cartoon they're pretty hopeless
so it gives reassurance for us that they
are hopeless I just really like when
finish at the glass and there's Jake and
he starts doing this and he's like now
my question is this did she know from
the beginning that they were in the
closet she specifically picked her nose
and flicked it right at Jake I'll say no
cuz I don't think she would have done
the album how do you know she didn't do
the album on purpose to make them feel
bad thank
she's got good senses but why would she
go to sleep and then wait for them -
because that would be funny why wouldn't
that I would do the exact same thing oh
I'm going to bed now
yeah I guess it would kind of be really
just to see what else they would do yeah
I mean she said herself oh it's no big
deal I do it all the same I do it all
the time in your place so I don't think
she would carry their weight so she
probably she came up you're sick
yeah could be you know that that be I'll
probably do something that you know
don't like mess with other stuff thank
you very well be that's my guess at
least I think she knew pretty much from
the beginning that's why the picking of
the nose that's why the whole opening up
and going oh there you are my boo yeah I
think it was kind of one of those things
like she knew and she's kind of like
pranking them if you will
could be it could very well be and will
win shock me so yes good stuff yeah I
liked it indeed but let's not end on
anything funny let's just out there okay
like we usually do